giono jig ball hi guys hope you have no
99 your life is different now and this
is a fun video that I've already done
with Hannah and mamrie but Tyler it's
your turn I love to have fun we are
going commencing dan has helped me go
back in time to some of your first
Instagram posts that the four of us are
going to look through right now and just
do a general review okay friends do
that's funny yeah let's look back at
some Tyler's first Instagram posts all
together on July 18 2012 what is this so
you can buy in the yearbook how is your
mother in chief and in the yearbook you
can buy your parents can buy you an ad
hi this is like a congrats and
resolution congratulations can I tell
you know everything about it for my
senior pictures I had two days of shoes
this is the thick one with long one day
with long hair one day after a haircut
this is after haircut I think I've seen
the shaggy tail so did most people do
two days of filming are you specifically
wanted both look stitch I wanted mouth
looks with multiple outfits in them for
one hour of each day I brought my dog
why are you on something smoked did you
have any leads up against Barnes and our
times 100% had one against the pillar so
we have this is open the shower curtain
this morning and found this April 6 2012
we have Herbal Essences some swabs
pendulum and a bud life I'm a big fan
and advocate of shower beer
I thought this is the main reintegrate
tiny pleasure I've moved on to a live
look when the show well that's very
grown up of you thank you I like that
Jen CK Roberts you said not a hater
what are you thirsty it's like a free
game no like everyone's getting ready so
drunk this baby this is this is what
happens within five minutes of unveiling
my world famous guacamole an actual baby
what makes your guacamole so elephant's
the love I had just shaved my head for
the UM five-year anniversary of Britney
shaking her head that's why you did that
yeah this is Q Bar I know exactly right
sure tiny chicken dressed as a pirate it
is someone said please do it looking at
old Instagram video fine family you were
just stocking Tyler's inside big time
[Music]
in 2013 because so I held up trying to
get the playlist that you didn't get
there to like midnight or something
crazy I was still being cheapest and I
was like you know what I will take the
bus with everyone from the airport and
we had to wait two and a half hours
before they took us to the hotel so I
got loaded I was like jamming booze I go
there like 10 room 10 beers I was like
mine there was a moment you ordered food
in the room in like we did our no filter
show and people are you ever
we were workshopping it and we had Tyler
come in and play a guest role what it
was I don't know what I do librarians
and he like asked a question or
something
[Applause]
I so what happens when like a guy and
like another guy do you clean that up it
was the first time I saw youtubers on a
stage like doing that and like people
coming and watching I was just so proud
individually wearing our own merch my
forehead looks like Charles the lighting
slightly better now but only slightly
[Music]
hey we made videos on each one of their
channels so they'll all be linked in the
description below go check them out
because they were as emotional
rollercoaster as this was there's a lot
that's it
batting was the k2 wave I didn't know
what to do well they put a little girl
in the industry - guys guest appearance
tendeth public's us doing that song
we're sure